[Music]
it's the first lesson for these kids at
the clean revised primary school in
Berlin the third graders are learning
English their teacher is at V Kumgang
she's a career changer in other words
she didn't originally study to become a
teacher she previously worked as a
translator but is now in the process of
retraining as a teacher a process that's
heavy on theory and practice
she's been in the classroom for about
six months now the learning curve has
been a steep one
this country I have a lot on my plate we
have about 10 hours of seminars a week
and I teach 19 hours on top of that and
of course you have to prepare the
lessons and grade homework
plan excursions it's a lot this country
to you
the 33 year old also teaches German and
math she has a mentor at the school an
experienced teacher the system is known
as a professionalization concept it's
one that's now common in Berlin
career changer employees teach alone
from their first day and often without
any sort of supervision they've often
not completed any sort of internship and
some don't have any other teaching
experience so there needs support from
colleagues at the school or what
including and become
the career changers are being hired to
fill the huge number of positions in
Berlin like in other German states many
more children in the capital are
currently entering the school system
than were predicted so many in fact that
this year more than half of all primary
school teachers hired to cover the
shortfall don't have degrees in
education
[Applause]
we asked the press secretary from the
responsible Department how planning
could go so wrong you
would have had to have started the
process 10 years ago at the universities
to now have those teachers in the school
of uninsurance will happen and why did
that not happen that's you'd have to ask
those responsible at the time you could
say at the time we didn't anticipate
what was coming in terms of population
growth
that growth helped Sabina Pender who
originally studied music to land a job
as a teacher three years ago she's also
a career changer I like my job really
and every day a bit more because now
after three years I have the feeling
that it's working as knoweth unlike
those who have studied teaching the
former piano teacher was thrown in at
the deep end from the first day
it would be a different thing if I could
be in a class for half a year with a
class teacher by my side to give me
feedback and support when I needed
but when you have to stand completely
alone in front of a third fourth or
fifth or sixth grade class and it's like
ok time to teach math
you can imagine what it's like
it was absurd I found it completely
absurd it helps absolute complete
absolute good for
Berlin isn't the only state in Germany
to hire career changer teachers across
the country more than 20,000 teaching
staff are needed at viche kumgang only
has to complete an 18-month training
program before she'll be eligible for a
permanent position and will be paid like
a normal primary school teacher but
without career changers like her the
school system across germany would
eventually break down